britain's place in the world our own
destiny changed by brexit
while the world order is shifting to
hostile russia
the unstoppable rise of authoritarian
china
the pm taking a hard-headed look at the
threats and opportunities we face
and signalling a return to hard power
an extra 24 billion pounds in defence
allowing the wholesale modernization of
our armed forces
and taking forward the renewal of our
nuclear
deterrent boris johnson with
controversial plans to reverse the
reduction in nuclear warheads
reminding the u.s the uk remains
militarily
onside in all our endeavors
the united states will be our greatest
ally
and a uniquely close partner in defense
intelligence
and security our relationship with the
world's second superpower more complex
at odds over the repressed uyghur people
hong kong
and china's military might in the
pacific but in need of beijing's
economic might
too there is no question that china will
pose a
great challenge for an open society such
as ours
but we will also work with china where
that is consistent
with our values and interests the pm
nuanced on china but many of his mps are
not
the grasping naivety of the cameron
osborne years still lingers on
in some departments of state this
government takes a very very clear-eyed
approach to what is happening in china
it is a balanced approach and one that i
think
the british people understand questions
unanswered too
over rumored army cuts the mass doesn't
add up
tell us now what's going to be cut so
this can be afforded
and opposition alarm over nuclear
proliferation
this review breaks the goal of
successive prime ministers
and cross-party efforts to reduce our
nuclear stockpile
it doesn't explain when why or for what
strategic purpose
the integrated review was billed as the
biggest examination of the uk's defense
security and foreign policy since the
cold war
and it feels a bit cold war at its heart
is an acknowledgment that the
international rules-based system
can no longer be taken for granted
but some of the solutions it proposes
around china
or our nuclear arsenal raises more
questions than it answers
but what we do know is the world is
changing and global britain
has to respond beth rigby sky news
westminster